today we're doing a test with
myheritage.com Taylor's going to do the
test what's your background my dad is
Irish and my mom's not totally sure you
get these two swabs and two vials and
what you're gonna do is take one swab
swab One Cheek while the other cheek put
in the vial put in that biohazard bag
seal that up we get a stamp and then we
send it off to Houston Texas got your
results now have you opened them no I
haven't let's dive in here ready to
explore your ethnicity yes I am oh okay
here we are 51.8 Irish Scottish and
Wells 37 Scandinavian did you ever I had
no idea about that and seven and a half
percent Baltic and then the rest Eastern
Europeans I think it's pretty cool
because I've never actually really dived
in to where I've come from so pretty
exciting stuff now you know exactly who
you are if you want to find out who you
are exactly my Heritage has a promo
going on right now enter the promo code
what if when you click the link and get
20 off